okay we'll go to 28
george holiday what is your view on
animal agriculture how can one reconcile
supporting immoral industries while
trying to live a morally good life
well
that's a fact about life
we cannot live our lives
without carrying out actions which we
know are immoral
like talking on this discussion
which is using energy
and use of energy
is destroying the environment
uh okay
so i talked before about driving to work
i have no other way to get to drive to
get to work can't go buy a bicycle can't
walk
can't take mass transportation because
there isn't any
so i drive to work well i know
that's harming the environment
i suppose you have an iphone
i don't happen to have one but most
people do
if you have an iphone
you're
contributing to the slaughter
of millions of people
in the eastern congo
uh where the basic minerals are
and we're warring tribes or
killing people to get hold of them
so that the multinationals who are
hovering over their shoulders can
get the minerals and turn them into your
iphone
just about every aspect of life
we're doing something that we know is
immoral
that's a fact and there's no way to
avoid it
uh absolutely no way if you want to
survive
well
that means we have to make decisions
to make choices to do
to to be as moral as we can be
within the limits of
maintaining
a passable existence
on animal agriculture
i think
you could ask the same about plant
agriculture
plant agriculture is
not a panacea it's destroying
agricultural lands destroying habitats
leading to the development of
coronaviruses for example
plenty of problems with animal with
plant agriculture
plenty more with animal agriculture the
way animals are treated as obscene
also very harmful to us
like
one of the main problems in contemporary
human life
very serious one
on a par with
probably on a par with
global warming nuclear war and others
is the
development of
antibiotic resistance
organisms uh
well that's serious
it's beginning to
reach the point where
health officials scientists are
concerned that
in a
maybe a couple of decades
it'll be impossible to carry out any
surgical procedures
or any most other medical interventions
because they'll simply be too dangerous
because of antibiotic resistant
organisms
well where's antibiotic resistance
coming from
mostly from overuse of antibiotics
and most of that
is in animal
or agriculture
you pack
cows and chickens and pigs into
virtually unsurvivable conditions
there's going to be disease spread
well you're trying to make profit
what you do is not
let them live on the range pack them in
tight and pack them full of antibiotics
the organisms develop resistance to the
antibiotics
pretty soon you have
the flood of antibiotic the resistant
organisms so we're killing ourselves
openly knowledgeably our children we're
killing them
okay
is it the right thing to do
only if you think
you want
that your goal in life is to murder your
grandchildren
because that's what we're doing
well there are answers
you can have
range-free animals for example but you
can stop the overuse of antibiotics you
could allow animals to have a decent
existence
up to the point we ask where you kill
them for eating
should we stop killing them for eating
probably but we're not at that stage of
civilization
it would mean mass genocide for humans
most people don't have the luxury
to
live a vegetarian diet that's a luxury
some people can do it
okay maybe that's their priority
there are plenty i should say that if
we're interested in
animal life
there's a much more important way to
save it
than a vegan diet
that's combating global warming
we're killing species at a phenomenal
level
a level that hasn't been seen for
65 million years
since the fifth extinction
and if we continue
heating the
climate we're going to wipe out
incom and
uncountable numbers of animals species
we don't even know about
most of our species we're never going to
heard of
okay
best way to protect animals
is to
quickly
settle the problem
of
overheating the environment
and then there are other things like
decent conditions for animals
cutting back shifting as much as
possible to
plant-based diets
ensuring that the plant-based diets
don't
have
the their own serious problems like
those i mentioned
all of that are things that can be done
but to try to live a moral life
is in fact hopeless
there is no way to do it
nobody's done it ever in history
nobody knows how to do it today